for sure young Emily yes
yes how would you feel let's personalize
this
16 years from now oh God you're
40 single no man no kids but you have
your [ __ ] together
you know money social podcast all that
how would you feel about that I think I
would be proud of myself first and
foremost that I did I am I do have my
[ __ ] together regardless of whether or
not I have a relationship or children I
think part of me would be very upset
that I don't have those things but I
would make the best of it gotcha well
how delusional is Emily
oh she's super delusional
eggs are delusional
but it's it's oh you don't know me
it's unfortunate because I mean you have
you have a lot of things going for you
but because you're on only fans like
you're going to be ruled out for most of
the guys you want and and actually that
in itself is delusional okay it's
unfortunate because without it like you
probably would be a contender for a lot
of the guys you want I have a question
do you think somebody who maybe they did
do only fans maybe they were in a
position in their life where that was
their choice do you think a woman who
has done only fans can be turned and I
know the comments are going to go crazy
yeah but do you think that it's possible
for those women to turn into like
committed wives here's my argument Saint
Mary Magdalene was a prostitute okay and
she ended up a saint so would you say
that people do have the ability to make
that decision and commit to it even if
they do have more of a promiscuous past
I mean unicorns exist but they're still
unicorns I actually asked my dad this
question I had a boyfriend that my dad
wasn't the biggest fan of and I was like
Dad you guys change like do people
change and he looked at me said yes they
get worse over time
trait you see now will probably be worse
than 10 years so choose carefully
I broke up with him
he said yeah in terms
hard work
so if you've really actually changed
something about yourself it's hard you
can't run from yourself yes so are there
unicorns yeah but are most guys going to
stick around to find out probably not
but if they were like a retired only
fans person and they were like I don't
want to die I would say better odds okay
I would say you have better odds if you
pick someone but is it probable right I
understand yeah and by the way just to
be clear so for our people in the
audience unicorns actually don't exist
yeah
just wearing like a birthday hat okay
well since you brought it up
um
Pearl what would you say to one of your
brothers you've got multiple brothers or
even a guy best friend who was gonna
marry
and only fans girl or some sort of sex
worker whether it's stripper is she
retired or is she [ __ ] she's currently
and or may retire when she gets married
what would you say to your brother
Andrew
um and I try not to be disrespectful
because you guys are here but but it
will be disrespectful and see how you
feel but it's just like I mean I would
say run I mean that that's it's what are
your future kids gonna think and like
and and that shows that she's putting
herself before you because like you know
you want to have a family someday you
know you want to have a kid someday and
you don't care because you put your body
on the internet and you know they're
gonna see that that's the type of girl
you're picking someone that puts herself
first and I want like for my brother I
want someone that puts the family before
themselves follow up and then I want to
get your guys perspective so we
interviewed um a few months ago Ali Ray
Ali Ray it was a former nurse she was a
nurse ICU nurse during covid yes yes yes
we started doing only fans she went from
making 80k a year to 80k a month she's
married with kids I've met her husband
and her kids on the podcast does sex
with her husband on camera what would
you say to that girl who has now become
officially a millionaire when she was
like just an average person with her
husband she does only fans what would
you say to that
um Haram
[Laughter]
I just think Google Haram real quick
I mean I just think it's a degeneracy
like again it's like forbidden who yeah
who cares how much money who cares how
much money you have you can't buy class
and your whole family like is going to
be looked at a certain way and that's
the Legacy you're leaving behind but and
if your husband is okay with it you know
she married a beta because no Alpha guy
would let his [ __ ]
are you gonna let your girl go on only
fans with you no because I make enough
money that I don't need you to be hoeing
it up but I'll rock around with it only
thing if you were for a couple months if
you were shout out to the girls I know
what I'm talking about if you were broke
if you were making 45 at one point
you're probably making average salary
right at that point if you're dating a
girl seriously for marriage would you
would you do only fans with her well
here's the deal when you're broke you're
desperate when you're desperate you're
stupid so guys who are broke they got no
money they are desperate and when you're
desperate you'll do stupid things I mean
and you'll get involved in things that
maybe you wouldn't co-sign on when you
had money money not only is money a tool
and a medium for exchange money allows
you to think bigger picture it provides
Clarity and allows you to do things that
you wouldn't necessarily do if you're
living paycheck to paycheck some of the
beauty of money is not only you know
being able to live the lifestyle you
want buy what you want but enables you
to make better decisions and not being
like the whims of emotions like I have a
buddy of mine who is paycheck to
paycheck broke as [ __ ] and someone
wanted to hire him and they say hey
they're paying 15 an hour he's like no
way I would never work for that I go
okay don't do it he goes
[ __ ] it I need the money I'll do it and
like that's what money does for you it
gives you better options anyway you were
going to say about the Haram well I mean
I I understand that some people use sex
as a tool to get to places but I just I
think your character is tested when you
have no money and a lot of people will
say that's hypocritical because I grew
up with money and a lot of people say I
don't understand it you know fair point
but it's like my dad was broke and my
dad he's just a hard worker so I just I
don't know I just look up to men like my
dad and I know it doesn't matter how
broke we were like he would never do
that okay but do you think that also
comes from your family being like Frugal
like you said because I also grew up in
a family home where like you know things
were very well set but I didn't grow up
where they were like throwing me like
six bands a month so like for me I like
I hold I hold value in like people going
through that struggle and like even
though you're raised in a home where you
can't you have the resources they're not
just given to you you know what I mean
so what so what's the question
um I forgot my question
watch the chat
um what would you say
to your brothers you have a brother uh
what would you also say let's say it's
brother best friend whatever who is
going to wife up and only fans girl what
would you say to him
my brother is the type
okay there are some men who don't
there's a lot of men who don't want to
work hard there's a lot there are men
who want to be stay-at-home dads and
they're like my girl's making money I'll
easily do that majority of our friends
who are in The Adult Space are in
relationships or are married okay but so
it's like you know can I change one
answer yeah there's one one of my
brothers I might say landslide do you
understand
for a certain type of guy because maybe
they don't have ambition drive work hard
enough that they're okay being kept by a
woman specifically a sex worker only
fans girl yeah so those types of men are
okay so here's my question to you how
long does that relationship last if the
girl is making well over six figures and
homie staying at home
my gut is telling me that homie unless
he's got a 12 [ __ ] inch [ __ ] that
guy's getting left in the dustpin of
History
even you are getting cut off yeah so my
problem is my question is even then your
brother's gonna have to make something
for himself because that dude who's
getting taken care of by a rich only
fans girl he's about to see you next
Tuesday like see you next Tuesday and
he's gonna be out the door in no time
anyway so he's gonna have to get a job
anyway yeah unless he's just totally
comfortable with being a kept man puss
ass dude
yeah I'm talking about your brother
right now
we love you Dave
no he's a good kid okay so forget about
your loser brother no offense what would
you say to your best guy friend who
actually has something going on in his
life who's gonna wipe up an only fans
girl do you want to take this yeah
absolutely I think I would ask him to
consider like I would with any woman
what she stands for what her morals are
what her intentions are with him and
really ask him like you said you don't
want to waste anybody's time you have to
ask the important questions that you
need to ask in a relationship does she
want kids if that's what you want does
she have the same values as him you
should really be delving into who she is
as a person and how it relates to him
okay fair enough I appreciate that so I
guess my question is this for that guy
should he be willing to look past his
girl getting naked on camera for other
men should he
why should he do that
I don't like this narrative there's one
right girl for you but you don't like
the narrative that there's no value in
women who do only fans and they lose
never say that I've never said that I
think I think it's needed in society
actually but but I'm a relationship like
I feel like that's for you okay what
value would you bring to a guy by like
showing your boobs why do you act like
the only value is what they do online
it's not like you're completely
dismissing like who somebody is as a
person same things Emily said I cook I
clean I suck good dick
listen I take accountability like
there's a lot of things you can value
and I make money by showing myself you
guys you guys said yourself on my show
that it causes you guys trauma so why
would I tell him to pick a girl that has
more trauma we said that we said that it
was an interesting take that you brought
up the fact that it might cause trauma
yeah
industry that it does cause drama for
some people but for us we've outweighed
the pros and cons and no you said that
some like when you do certain things it
causes trauma I think I said I I crossed
my own boundaries and decided after a
while I was like okay that's not where I
want to go
but that's just me just being honest
with myself you know like you know what
let me take a step back by the way
I here's my message to you guys
I'd be
I'm friends with you guys I'm cool with
you guys I'll party with you guys I'm
friends with only friends girls I've
hooked up with only fans girls I've got
no problem with sex workers I partied
with strippers I've done the whole thing
all that love you you guys are much
needed in society you guys
you are a major major benefit for
society there's one caveat
most men should not be marrying these
types of girls there are exceptions but
most meant because I'll tell you why men
are territorial they don't want some
dude they don't want like if my girl was
naked if my girl was the hottest
stripper in the club the hottest
but she was giving lap dances to
everyone there's like a side of a man
that's like yeah I'm not good with that
number two men care about their image
and their status in society so when
they're sitting around a circle what
does your wife do what does your wife do
what does your wife do what does your
wife do oh yeah my wife is an only fans
girl they're gonna feel that from the
other men and they're gonna be like
and that's fine and that's fine but most
men are not cool
what percent what percent of men don't
give a [ __ ] would you say just by
talking about and actually and actually
don't because men will tell you things
to get laid like for example yeah we got
to be like oh six foot like tall gingers
are my type yeah okay I'll give you my
standard answer for any type of question
like this okay and it might be higher or
lower I always implement the 80 20 rule
that's with anything okay 80 20 rule 80
of men are not going to be comfortable
with this there's going to be some
exceptions right some dudes that are
just hey I'm down for whatever what
percent of the 20 would you say make
enough money or be okay with it and make
enough well only 90 87 make over a
hundred grand anyway sorry 13 make over
100 Grand so
87 are not going to be in your category
anyway so if you're just going to do
quick math and you're gonna say all
right if there's a hundred guys 87 of
them are out now of those 13 okay so 80
of that so now amazing so 10 men are out
so you have three men out of a hundred
who make over six figures that may be
willing to wife up and only fence girl
not saying it's not realistic unicorns
do kind of exist at this point but three
percent of men would be cool with this
that's my number okay what do you think
not to your right
yeah that's it drop the mic we're done
here guys Delhi uh from your perspective
would you wipe up an only fans girl no
sir you would not no and would you
reveal how much money you make a year uh
about 40 Grand so let's Okay so he makes
40 Grand he's a little above average and
do you have a girlfriend no okay now why
wouldn't your for this conversation
you're how old 23 23 yeah so you're a
young guy you don't make six figures
you're a young dude let's just say for
the state of this conversation you're an
average man okay I think you have you
happen to be above average he's a great
editor
um and he's a great friend
why wouldn't you as an average man wife
up in only fans girl what is it to you
forget about me forget about the fact
that I'm this dude I host the show and I
make money you're the average dude
you're playing the average dude why
would you not wipe up an only person I
just think I'm more focused on the past
I don't really want to think about that
the whole time I'm with you that you're
hitting up somebody else or maybe making
money by flirting with somebody else
it's just not my thing at all and
there's a is there a part of you and
it's okay because I'll admit it that
maybe you're a little insecure about
that because this dude I don't know yeah
I agree yeah I don't know because men
are concerned about a woman's past and a
woman is concerned about a man's future
so what about transparency like if the
woman is like here's my only fans login
go ahead see whatever you want like
they're fully ingrained with what
they're doing and have that I feel like
that's the worst thing you could do I
don't know I feel like when it comes to
you want your man to see exact so here's
my advice to you and this is my advice
to all women once you've done it already
the cast that's out the bag keep doing
it meaning like no guy's gonna be like
yeah she was doing only fans but she
quit she quit for me and she stopped the
fact that you're already doing it yeah
yeah you're labeled it only fans girl
keep rocking like my advice to you is
your friend who's how's you on the show
you've already done it yeah your titties
are on camera yeah you did it already
it'd be it'd be for the win like if Nat
was ever going to do this I'd say not
I know your mama I know your papa
you okay like these are the things I
would like you to consider before you do
this but once she's already gone down
that path too late she belong to the
streets and that's it she's a street
walker at that point but I also think
like men also value privacy with their
women you know like I'm sure like a guy
wouldn't want to be like bro look at
your girl like I follow her only fans
you know so I think that's where like
men that were like because like you said
men can be insecure and they aren't you
right shoot I can be insecure sometimes
so I think because of that that is a big
trigger for men you know the idea of
like my homeboys watching my girl I
think that's where they get a little bit
uncomfortable and I don't know there's
value in privacy there's value in those
things so it really just depends like
the life you want and I feel like you'll
be able to find the person who will
accept that you know in certain places I
think that there's like nothing sexier
though than like a man who knows what he
wants and doesn't give a [ __ ] and he's
really strong and who he is and his own
masculinity to not let that bother him
and there are those men out there and
but I just I just think it's selling a
dream like remember 45 one out of every
two of us is expected to be single and
childless so a lot of 20 30. so so so a
lot of girls there's no happy end ending
it's bio dog and die alone and I think I
think it sounds nice to say oh there's
someone for everyone you have you're the
right person that's just not true yeah
by the way I like you have no idea like
I respect what you guys do you guys own
it and that's amazing and if you were
gonna stop doing only fans I would say
why you're already making money you're
already killing you've already gone down
that path yeah but I don't even look at
you girls as like these only fan
terrorist women that like everybody says
comedians as Talent like for me I don't
even like that like
I mean only fans girls can be funny
likeable like cool like but it's just
you have to understand that's how men
see it yeah and it doesn't sound nice
and I'd rather say oh there's someone
for everyone that sounds nice by the way
I I fully endorse that the reason I have
you guys on the show is because I think
you're great I think you're amazing
you're not we're not uh insulted right
now no no no you don't need to like
explain I mean I like the words of
Africa hear me out
um like I said before I'll hang out with
you guys on part of you guys I'll bang
only fans girl I'm just not gonna marry
them there's a big distinction it's a
big distinction so if you want this high
value man that makes 10 million dollars
a year that does all this that's going
to pay for all your [ __ ] why would he
pick someone like you when he can pick a
girl that hasn't exposed herself on
camera that's the question that you need
to ask here's my final point to you and
then we'll move on
um you never know what will trigger that
man that man you're talking about this
confident man he's great he's gonna
accept me for who I am all it takes is
one stupid situation to happen where his
grandma asks him I heard your
girlfriend's a hoe he's like what or
some dude shut up sends a picture sends
a picture to the group chat with all his
buddies yo and he's being funny slasher
[ __ ] yo check out Doug's girl naked
and now all his boys and now his boys
are clowning on him so you never know
what's going on
he's not chick he's not choosing the
right men to be around if that's it stop
it that's so true
yeah you guys are looking at it as a
woman yeah so is he also not choosing
the right Grandma yeah [ __ ] his grandma
I hope she dies
grandma
it's my grandma's dead his grandma can't
be alive wow I have a question for you
Adam yeah a nice little old tomato so if
you found your ideal woman and she was
just exactly what she wanted but you
guys got married you had your first kid
already and we'll say
three years into the marriage first can
first can yeah take your sip of water
um you found out that she used to you
found out she used to do only fans six
years ago but her content was deleted
but there's maybe like one or two photos
out there would you initiate a divorce
I would expect every man out there
before they [ __ ] propose to get a
married what don't I know about you what
am I gonna find out about you five years
from now that it's gonna make me want to
divorce you tell me now and also there's
going to be a prenup and if and by the
way I want her to ask me that like
before I started with valuetainment you
know what Pat asked me what he said
before you get hired
tell me everything that I'm going to
find out right now up front I go Pat
I used to party a lot as a kid never got
in trouble I you know people will tell
you stories that Adam used to go out and
be wild but there's like there's no jail
stuff there's no nothing got no criminal
stuff I've never ripped anybody off the
worst thing you're gonna hear about me
is you know that dude could party and
he's like [ __ ] yeah bro
I'd like to know all the skeletons in
the closet up front Okay good question
well what about the girl nudes for free
I don't know if I would divorce her at
that point three [ __ ] you'd marry a
free [ __ ] okay say that question again
I said what about girls who are
constantly texting dudes sexing dudes
sending nudes the most women are doing
that with men that they're interested in
yeah and they're doing it for free and
those same nudes have been passed around
in group chats because well this will be
this will be an answer don't don't
listen to what I do listen to what I say
okay because you girls out there that
are sending me news respect to you keep
them calm whoever
um I'll tell you the those girls are
actually bad business women if you're
just throwing your [ __ ] out there
would you pick a girl she's got three
bodies but she was on only fans or 50
bodies
um
um you can't say neither
I would say it's not fun unless we pick
if I had to pick one
I would pick
[ __ ] yeah think about it so it's three
bodies I mean her body count yeah but
she was on only fans yes versus 50 bucks
that's a great question okay I have one
question for you she's not [ __ ] on
only fans okay thank you my question for
you is how old is she
let's say let's say mid-20s 25
are you talking about by 25. okay so by
25 if you [ __ ] 50 dudes
okay what if I okay
I want to know when it switches so 30 30
bodies who you picking yeah I'm now I'm
leaning towards the 30 girl now you're
okay 40 bodies but how would you know
her bodies yeah
okay she's taking [ __ ] literally I'm
playing games with you I'm trying to
help you try to avoid the question
because you'd pick the only fans
so the question is the question is this
doing only fans is worth how many people
20 bodies 50 bodies
not only fans does it not would that not
sway more in that favor if she's not
honestly I swear to God in my life I've
never been on only fans so I don't know
what's doing I don't want to like
educate you yeah I mean give me the PG
the rated R and the rated X version so I
know girls who have never taken their
underwear off and they like show their
boobs I know girls who never take their
underwrap and put nipple pasties on and
they do like twerking and like new like
nudes but you don't so that's PG-13 guys
I like Playboy yeah and then I have
friends who would just do full-blown
gangbangs oh yeah
and they have to like gangbangs orgies
and then they have to like meet up with
others I'm out I'm out
of camera I'm out so three bodies and
she's been gang bang on camera
you usually have to pay a monthly
subscription most girls because it's
good for good for business it's bad for
business to put your nudes out there for
free or even after a subscription you
have the pay-per-view messages so like
like my feed looks like someone's normal
Instagram feed like me and bikinis Okay
and like I don't know whatever you keep
doing you I don't know I got to get back
to you on that we gotta last couple
times before the end we got I told you
like what is it 130 around 30 he he
picked the girl with the 30 Bodies Okay
50 he he was probably the only fans girl
if you did 50 lie like what are you
talking about as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible